ナーラ
3割なんてん棘はを
ならなぁままわー
社長ですシェイク的には冬なのでみなさんの地域に言ってかわかんないんですけども
みなさんのそういう地域によっては勇気が降ってるかもしれないまた朝寒すぎて a
道路が氷漬けなってるかしれないですよね徳井はやっぱり気温が低いので雪が降ったり
道に氷が張って浮かせベルことがあるんですよ
つるっつるにね僕もたい理由出身なんで雪のコースを知ってるんでこれの危険
米滑ってこけて頭とかウット本当に危ないんねそういう事の為にこういう道具があり
ます
パンポッドバックするバッグぽっぺんぷコロバンド
これネーミングフェイスが疑う必要滑り止めでございますこういう感じで苦痛に増える
ことによってそのくせが滑らなくなるみたいです
大面積で安心おこう足に優しい設計ということで絶対にしてる時も全然ライ角みたいな
のでこれないつければ氷と空気とか道でも余裕でできるんですよ
低頃
バンドというものがあるんですけどもらもちろん滑らないっていうことは場所を問わ
ないんだと思いますあこういう感じに f はこういう感じがこういう感じでござい
ます右だ左がちゃんとあります
それに取り付けるってこういう感じがちょっと小さくに対する分こういう感じですここ
でその滑りが止まるみたいです
廃人右左ば次いでございますこのクソハックとことによって
大丈夫こんなに住めないよね多分大丈夫だと思う滑らないって書いてあるから大丈夫だ
と思う言えないかちょっとローソンだらけにしますてその上はボケがもこれをつけ全力
疾走しますよローソンなり負けて滑った道を安心して隠れずにポッポ組占めるかって
いうのをちょっとやってみようと思いますでは以降
ポンポンポポポンと取ったいって言って僕は大丈夫で今後
の今日の会場ですこの道に今からブルーシートを引きますで弾いた苦しいただ上に老将
を塗って都合だけの抓りダメ付きの靴が歩きますや走り今走りますと
走る走って遊ぶ大丈夫では神事ででは炎でずれないって言えたらにすべらないんですよ
多分なぜも僕はでも体を張って検証するんで走ります
犬が思って大変だなぁん
par
こんなもんでしょひとまずローソンは聞ける環境は作りました
カーサ塗っていきます俺さぁなぜことを考えたんだろうさっき静岡からちゃ行ってきた
ばっかりなんですよね明日すぐ東京だったためねほんとにローション塗って暇はないん
だと思うそれでもさー
と言いたいんだよ
岩井いきますお家でなくわあああ
どうでしょうかこれはやばいふわぁ
もうそうですから今から実際に行くぞ本当にすぐなんか底を打つと確かめてみようと
思いますてない校
ちょっと危ないかヘルメットかぶるね俺ここで死ぬわけにはいかないからなというわけ
でこちらの2つですねハッ滑り止め
全て試した靴を2つ使ってちょっと歩いてみようと思いますさっきあんだけ滑ってたら
多分大丈夫だと思うんだけども書いてはちょっと幅と言ってみようと思います大丈夫俺
ができる地域ます
トゥまあ普通
すぐながらくっ
って方にすべらないその不可
で行って混ぜ込んでくれない頃
これ地獄ねえませ本当にじゃないんです
tar